awesome so yeah this is full stack
serverless with
typescript um yeah i'm jake partoush
i am director of web and mobile at
object partners
i've been doing development for quite
some time now
specializing kind of in in front-end
stuff um
historically with a reactant view uh but
more
recently i guess i guess sort of my
whole career i've been i've been doing
full stack development for
for clients um so more recently i've
been
working a lot with serverless and
typescript and so i kind of wanted to
bring everything that i've learned and
kind of
share with you all in my free time i
have
two kiddos uh they keep me busy in my
free time
um i have a golden retriever um we've we
built several snowmen
uh this this uh this winter so
um i consider myself a mediocre snowman
builder
so let's kind of dive right into it what
it is full stack
um so i would say prior to 2010 there
there was no
you know there wasn't a full stack term
around
uh there was just a stack and
there was no front-end developers or
back-end developers or full-stack
developers
uh developers were just developers
the full-stack term kind of came became
more popular
around you know the early 2010s
so i think this kind of came came in
with the
single page application movement so
angularjs
kind of popularized the single page
application so moving a lot of
the logic from um you know to the front
end to the client side
and so that allowed people to specialize
in you know front-end development
and so if there was a you know front end
and a back-end development
uh paradigms then the full stack was you
know the full stack developer was
someone who could
work in the front end or the back end
and kind of be comfortable
so historically this has kind of been
you know that front end
and back end split and that makes you a
full a full stack developer if you feel
comfortable you know working
working with both what i would say in
2021 is that's
kind of changing a little bit um and
adding in
infrastructure as well so the way the
the reason i say this is because you
know in 2021 a lot of
our applications that we're building are
are more cloud native
so we're using services you know whether
it be aws gcp
azure and when our applications are
written
for those services and we kind of need
to know how those applications or those
those services work to make our
applications run well
so i would say in 2021 we kind of
not only need to be concerned about the
front end and the back end
but also infrastructure
and so some of us might myself included
might might feel a little bit like this
you know you're a little bit uh back end
back end heavy and you know
um you know a little bit leaned on the
front end
or or maybe more commonly here at
nebraska js so like this your
your front end you're an expert on the
front end but your back and skills
aren't
aren't quite aren't quite there but i
guess what i'm trying to um
what i what i my goal is to kind of give
us some skills to
hopefully be these uh majestic um
horses and we can we can be full stack
developers through and through um and be
productive at the same
time so one of the tools or or
development
paradigms that we can use in doing this
is serverless
so why serverless
i'd say the from a business cost
perspective one of the most
appealing appealing things is that
serverless architectures
your your costs scale with your scale
so you you're paying per request of your
application
so in a traditional in a traditional set
uh or traditional server
application uh you kind of see this step
stone pattern of scaling so
you have an application with a baseline
set of you know i need
one small uh server to run my
application
and then once you kind of get to peak
load peak scale for that server you
have to upgrade either you know double
you have two small servers running or
you have
a medium size server running and then
you kind of get that step stone pattern
all the way up
to scale with your application as it
kind of grows in popularity
but with the serverless uh the
serverless architecture you're kind of
from ground from ground zero you know it
costs nothing
and then when you scale you know to a
high load then it costs you know as much
as
as much just as much as you're using and
not more and so where i really think
that's
important or i really think that comes
into play is kind of
at the lower end of the scale that's
where a lot of interesting things happen
because you know you don't you don't
necessarily
for test environments and and and all
that when you're first starting out
um you don't want your application to
cost a lot of money so
you can spin up an environment you can
spin down an environment
and you know you're not going to spend
be spending a lot of money with
serverless because
you're not using it or people aren't
using it a whole lot so
um so yeah during this uh pandemic times
my wife and i have been watching a lot
of uh television as most might
attest to so we've been specifically
watching a lot of hgtv type shows
and so i kind of wanted to explain the
difference between traditional and
serverless applications
from a cost perspective with a
serverless house hunter's example
so seemingly when when folks are
are buying a house at least on tv
they they are always like you know i
need a dining table that can seat 12
people
even though there were only two people
that live in this household we need
someone
a dining room table that can seat 12 so
that you know when all the family comes
over for christmas then
um we can we can have everyone you know
sit at the table
and so i i'd consider that as peak load
purchasing
so they're they're buying the house or
buying the table um
to fit as as many people as you know
will ever be in the house
and so they're kind of over over
provisioning uh their house
uh to to support that peak load
on the contrary like a serverless
example as far as house hunting might go
um something i learned about recently i
guess i didn't know existed
was that there's people that are airbnb
nomads
and so they don't own a house they just
travel from airbnb to airbnb
i would say that's a good analogy for
serverless because
you know if they have a party coming up
they might rent a bigger
airbnb if they are just hanging out at
home then
you know just something small like this
all right so serverless isn't all just
about
cost costs and you know pay per usage
i'd say it's a lot about productivity as
well
so i think when i think of serverless i
think of lego with
lego building blocks so you have lots of
different
managed services that you're kind of
building together to to construct your
application logic
so your your business logic those are
the things that kind of make your
business different
than other businesses is that that core
business logic the application
you know that user experience piece so
you don't want to spend a lot of time
you know managing servers or configuring
authentication systems you want to spend
all of your time you know working on
that core business logic and i think
that serverless fits in that
that paradigm really well
so let's take a look at a common aws
infrastructure
using kind of some serverless building
blocks so this is using aws
and some of aws's managed servers or
services not all services on aws are
serverless
but i picked some for this example so
this is kind of showing a new user
signup flow so we have
a user they come in via their phone and
they want to sign up for
um you know then the service they want
to they want to start using whatever
you're building
and so their first interaction with the
services they need to create
a new account via cognito um
and then you know after they've
authenticated with cognito they're
redirected to cloudfront and can get the
website that's hosted in s3 up through
and
and kind of start working with the
website
cognito might tell that user or take
that user that was created
and pipe it through an api gateway
lambda connection
to get stored in dynamodb
and then that might asynchronously
trigger off an email to let the user
know
or to give them some sort of welcome
email or something like that
so that's just kind of a typical um
server list you take these
different serverless building blocks
piece them together to create a new user
signup flow
so one of the common um
common common things i hear about people
that are kind of nervous and getting
into service
serverless architecture is you know
isn't it aren't i
you know really tied to aws is
is it kind of am i building my
application on idea
on aws and i can't ever move off of it
well what i would say about
about using these serverless pieces as
you know decoupled building blocks
is that you can take the core pieces of
your business
and if you need to switch them out with
something else then you can
so in this example we've taken out
our cognito building block here
and replace it with us opt 0 which is a
third-party
authentication provider and we've also
taken out our ses
component and replaced it with sungrid
so you can kind of pick and choose the
different pieces of your application
that are important to you
and if a third party provider does that
specific thing really well then you
might choose
that thing we still have our core
application logic in aws and that's
that's probably okay
aws does these things really well some
of those
you know side services are kind of the
pieces that you might want to pick
pick and choose to kind of differentiate
yourself or build a build a better
experience with
by kind of going custom you could build
you could build a custom
building block if it's a really
important piece to your business or you
could pick an off-the-shelf third-party
piece to kind of put in there
so why typescript there's
roughly a million a million reasons to
use typescript and nick
you see you can can name them all but
i'm just going to focus on one for this
uh talk today and that's because
typescript is supported
um it's the only language that i can
really think of
that is supported on modern front-end
frameworks back-end frameworks and also
infrastructure frameworks
and i'd say that this is infrastructure
as code
with typescript is a relatively new
thing
and so that's kind of going to be one of
the key pieces that we're going to show
here
in a minute
so without further ado
let's get on to our demo but maybe i can
just stop right here for a second and if
anyone has any questions
we can talk about them now
alrighty we'll keep going and
be a couple more opportunities for
questions after the demo and everything
so
um so the demo that i built out for this
talk
is a an admin panel for
kind of a um an ordering system
so you can kind of see in this
screenshot we get got a couple orders
coming in
um one second i want to dock
this zoom thing somewhere else
maybe there's no good spot
for the zoom controls it doesn't matter
where you put it it always covers up the
next thing you need
um yeah one second
how do you actually move it i i've been
using teams for so long that
is there a way to dock it to the side
maybe i think you just click and drag it
oh there we go it's better thank you
okay all right so uh this is our
live running uh our live running demo
and so if i refresh here you can see it
has a little loading spinner
and then it loads our recent activity
our orders for our kind of our order
management system
and so this is running in aws it's got
its own url
and everything and so what this is
is a react application with um
using snowpack that's not really super
relevant but
it's using a graphql api running on
behind an api gateway on a lambda and
then pulling those records from dynamodb
so we can kind of look at the
architecture here
so we have we have all those pieces
together and these are kind of our
building blocks for
our application today
and so what we're going to do here in a
minute is
kind of go through and make a couple of
changes to our demo app and kind of
illustrate how
typescript and can help us manage our
our application across the entire stack
and
just kind of see how those changes flow
through so
let's switch over to vs code
so let's kind of get the lay of the land
here and our vs code
project so we have at the kind of the
base of our project we have a source
folder
so this is our react application it's a
lot like create react app
all these files in here are all
typescript files tsx files
so in our components folder we have you
know the components for our application
um so that's kind of your standard top
down
application and then all the components
are nested under there
in our functions folder that's kind of
where our api lives so we have a graphql
file
and a graphql.ts file in here and
so this is an apollo server running in a
lambda
and it's kind of responsible for
interacting with dynamo pulling those
records and
returning the responses and finally we
have our infrastructure folder so this
is our
cloud development kit our amazon cdk
project and so the thing that's kind of
unique or interesting about
cdk is that it's natively
written in in typescript and it has
ports for other languages as well
i pick typescript because i like the
fact that i can write
all my code in my entire project my
frontend my backend and my
infrastructure all in typescript
so we can look in here and take a look
at our infrastructure stack
and maybe just for a moment just take a
look at you know how to create a table
with
the cdk because this is maybe the most
unfamiliar part
for for many folks is this uh
infrastructure as code
with typescript so we're importing a
table construct from
the aws cdk package so you can kind of
see up here
we have the aws cdk dynamodb
package and we're importing table from
there so we're creating a new table and
then we specify some
configuration for it so for demodp
tables
partition keys and sort keys are are
required to create them
so we're defining the name of our
partition key and the name of our
sort key i shouldn't say sort key is
required it's not technically required
you can just go with the partition key
but
these are some of the configuration
parties on properties on a table
also switching the billing mode to pay
per request
so kind of like like we want our service
serverless applications to be we only
want to pay for what we use
by default the billing mode is
provisioned so you can provision
you know units of of dynamodb
pre-provision that if you'd like this
removal policy isn't really
relevant we probably wouldn't have this
set to destroy in production
i'm just doing that for a quick
prototype
thing all right so we have kind of the
lay of land
um understand what's kind of how our
project's set up
so the first thing that we're going to
do
uh is we're going to make a code change
to our project
to allow for our if we go back to our
dashboard maybe it'll
make a little bit more sense right now
we're only showing pending orders
and our orders recent activity page
we're going to make a change
to the project to allow either pending
or
shipped orders to show up in here so
where we're going to start is at our
graphql schema
so this is kind of the contract between
our front end and our back end code
and and maybe before i get too much
further
i want to note that i'm using
another library that's kind of cool in
my opinion
to integrate our graphql schema with our
typescript types
so that project is called graphql
codegen
and so i have this pulled up this is
their website
graphql code gen it's an open source
project and basically what it does is it
takes
takes in your graphql schema and can
spit out
typescript types and so we're going to
use that pretty extensively
here in this example i should note that
in order to do
you know full stack typescript you don't
need to use graphql and you don't
necessarily need to use
graphql code generator i just did this
for the example because it's easy to
illustrate
um the benefits of the typing system
across your application with with these
two tools so
the first thing that we're going to do
like like i mentioned is that we're
going to
we're going to switch this query this
find orders
query to take an array of statuses
rather than
a single status so we're going to going
to switch this to
plural statuses and take an array so
it's requiring
that you pass in an array with at least
one item
and so that's the only change we need to
make to our our base schema file
we have a dashboard graphql file and
this holds our queries for the
dashboards we're going to make the same
corresponding changes here
and rename these things from status to
statuses
cool so
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to run yarn generate so that's
going to
kick off our graphql code generator so
it's going to slurp up these
graphql files and spit out typescript
definitions that kind of correspond
to our our
graphql schema and so we see that this
ran pretty quickly and it spit out those
those typescript files so the next thing
we're going to do is run yarn build on
our project to make sure
to see you know we changed some stuff in
our graphql schema we would expect some
things to break
and we do so the first thing that we see
is
uh our resolver our
lambda function has
sorry um has a type error now so we have
uh our status you know we rename that to
statuses so
our type are our types that were
generated for our
graphql function are no longer matching
what we had coded so we're going to
change that from status to statuses and
change this from status to statuses as
well
now our function is was expecting a
single status but
um we needed an array of statuses now so
luckily i wrote something ahead of time
and we can just
fetch orders by status codes instead of
statuses
so this is kind of cool graphql code jen
took our schema
and generated the resolvers fully typed
resolvers
uh for our schema and so we got
type safety for our our graphql function
in here
and so that's pretty neat so let's head
back to
here and see okay we have another error
in our dashboard.tsx file
so our dashboard tsx file is kind of the
main
route entry level for our dashboard if
we remember
our dashboard is our application
running here so it's got you know this
this recent activity stuff in here so
we have a typescript error and it's
saying you know uh we're passing in a
variable called status with status
pending
if we remember our our the thing that
we're trying to
to fix or the the business requirement
we're trying to solve is to
pass in both status and
shipped statuses to our dashboard
so let's go ahead and change this to an
array
and you see we've got some autocomplete
in here too um
so now we can pass in our
our array of statuses both pending and
shipped
one thing that i should note is it's
using our graphql code generator also
can generate um
you can define plug-ins for let's go and
look at that real quick
define plug-ins and one of them is
react-apollo
so the react-apollo plug-in will
generate these
these hooks for you so we have a hook
that's
called use find orders query so it it
generates
that hook and fully types all the
variables that you pass into it
so that's really cool we can have fully
typed
integration on our front end to make
sure that we're interacting
with our graphql schema like like we had
planned
so let's run yarn build one more time
the front end completed and
the infrastructure his code is done
awesome so
for our first example we we kind of
recap what we did here we changed
status to statuses we passed in an array
of statuses
into our query we ran the code generator
it updated all the types for our
application
for our graphql resolvers we we caught a
an error
where we were referencing status instead
of statuses
and we needed to fetch
order orders by status codes instead of
a singular status code
also in our dashboard we were passing a
status variable instead of statuses and
not
an array and so we kind of caught an a
we caught errors on both
uh the front-end side of our code and
the back-end side so we had that fully
typed
further for both things and that's
that's pretty neat
all right so for our next
next example this is more of a not
necessarily a business requirement but
kind of a code cleanup thing
so for our order object we specified an
attribute called
customer full name and so we decided as
a development team
we wanted to switch this
to be its own type and so we're going to
make a new type called a customer
and so this customer has an id
first name
last name
and full name
cool so we have a new type called
customer
that has these a couple of new
attributes and then also has the full
name again
so we're going to switch our order to
use a customer
instead of
the customer type instead of having
customer full name kind of in our order
at the root level so
we made our change to our base schema
again we'll have to open up that
that dashboard graphql file and
we're going to have to change this
fragment where it was pulling
the customer full name to grab
our complex you know attribute customer
and then we only need we don't need the
first name
we don't need the last name or the id we
just need the full name from here
so those are the two changes we're going
to make to our
graphql schema so if we run
yarn generate again it should spit out
some new types for us
and while we're in here we can run yarn
build to see where our new type errors
are
cool so we have one here a new file we
haven't looked at yet
it's called order row row.tsx
so if we go back to our application our
order row
component is this this row has an order
item in it
it says order from molly sanders
so right now it's we we see there's an
error
order from and then it's referencing
customer full name in here and we want
it to reference
our new path which is customer dot full
name
so i think that one is is very special
because
uh if this were written in javascript i
almost certainly would have forgotten
to change this way deep down here in our
component tree
and i would have found that bug at
runtime and
hopefully not in production but maybe in
production as well
so i i'm a fan of that
all right so let's run yarn build again
see if we have any more errors
okay so looks like we have an error
in our infrastructure project which we
haven't had yet so it looks like our
front end
and back end built fine but then when it
tried to build infrastructure project
we got an error here in our
infrastructure stack so let's go take a
look
sometimes it takes vs code a minute to
catch up
there we go so to kind of give a little
bit of background on on why this error
is happening we have to understand a
little bit about dynamodb
so for dynamodb you can by default query
on the partition key
and sort key in combination but if you
want to do
more complex type queries you have to
create
secondary indexes and so that's what i
had done already is created a secondary
index
uh to query on for some of the more
complex queries for this application
and so we see we're defining our
our global secondary index here it's got
a name it's
it's really similar very similar to the
way you define a table
uh you define the partition key and the
sort key
the thing that's kind of unique about
this one is we didn't want to copy over
all of the attributes from the table we
only wanted to copy over the attributes
that we specified in here
so copying over all the attributes in an
index can be
you know kind of over over provisioning
or more expensive than than we need it
to be so we're only copying over the
ones that we need
so we kind of specified those in a
list here and this type
if we kind of dig into why this area is
showing up a little bit more
is defined up at the top and it's saying
that
we want our the available attributes
to be our keys on our order object
and so that order object that order type
is
defined generated based off of our
graphql schema
and so we can only specify the keys
if they exist on our order type and
right now since we changed
what our order looks like a customer
full name is no longer there
so to fix that we we can
look at the different attributes we have
on order and we see that we have
customer now and not customer full name
so that
fixes our our attributes that we're
copying over to our secondary index
and i guess i just want to reiterate
this is
this is kind of a cool um
a cool bug or a type check
that we found here basically by
uh changing our our graphql schema and
regenerating some types
we were able to find a potential bug
way down here um in our front end code
and then we're also able to make sure
that
we had taken into account that this
secondary index is changing in our
dynamodb
table or needs to change likely this
might have been forgotten if it was in a
yaml file
or you know some json config
we don't type check those and so we
might not have found that and
the next time we queried on this index
that the attribute that we're expecting
to be there
may not have been there so i think
that's that's really cool and kind of
shows the power of
using typescript across the entire
application both the front end
and the back end and the infrastructure
is that
we can kind of define those you can have
that type safety across the entire
the entire stack that helps you
basically find all the bugs in your ide
before you even
build and push to production so
the to kind of um bring a full circle
like a like a good
celebrity chef i already have baked this
application and we're going to take it
out of the oven now
so you see we have this preview url that
i generated for this
application and you see we are have our
orders
both pending and shipped orders are in
here so
yay awesome so back to
here this time i'm gonna stop
for a few seconds i do have a little bit
more but it's uh kind of
extra content so we have any questions
about what we've talked about so far
now would be a great time
i was told that on video calls you're
supposed to count to 12.
there is a question in the chat awesome
uh from from wayne i'll read it can you
walk through
the yarn build to show how they are
connected
yeah i can
so the build
so the the two things it does is it does
a snowpack build so we're using snowpack
under the hood for the front end code
and the reason it finds also those
we're not using i should switch this to
use
yarn workspaces or lerna and so we could
kind of run these all in one command but
basically since it thinks that this
functions folder is part of the
the react project so it goes ahead and
checks
does the type checking for that as well
in the snowpack
build command and so that build command
will
after it runs the type checking and
everything it'll
spit out all the the javascript and html
files that are required to
deploy your react application and then
after that it goes into our
infrastructure folders and runs a synth
and so that's a special cdk command
that basis basically generates the cloud
formation
templates from your typescript code
so it executes all of your typescript
typescript code in your stack
and generates cloud formation templates
off of that so
we'll take a look at that real quick
generates a huge
json file that you don't have to write
by hand anymore
you can just write typescript and it'll
generate the json for you
and that's what ends up getting deployed
to aws
i have a question um kind of about the
about the the functions themselves like
when you're developing those maybe i
missed it but how do you um
work on those locally or do you have to
like deploy each time to
to test those um yeah there's a couple
of different ways
so depending on so for this example
specifically i could run this locally
because it's just
basically apollo server so i could run
this function locally
a lot of times though with serverless
architectures
since the deploys in the cloud
environment happen
are happening faster and faster every
day a lot of times i'll just push up a
deploy preview
kind of like i had here and so you know
that you're running on all
all the infrastructure that you know a
real dynamodb table
real lambdas and you know you have a
unique url that you can use to test your
application so
a lot of times i will just deploy it
and you know that may take a little bit
longer than developing locally
uh if i'm if i'm feeling like i'm not
very confident in my code
then um i'll write some just tests
around the functions
and see you know just kind of get that
initial like
i have accounted for all the things i
think i should account for and then
um after those just has passed then i
might uh just push it up as a deploy
preview
so i'll kind of talk in a second
um if we don't have any other questions
i can talk how this
this function itself gets deployed
because
typescript isn't natively supported by
aws and
lambda functions so we can kind of talk
about how that all works if we don't
have any other questions
if you do have questions i would like to
hear that but i would just
throw out there that uh aws lambda
fairly recently like in the last few
months
uh now has like first party support for
containers
so there are docker base images that can
run a lambda function locally it's
really slick if you haven't tried it
cool awesome yeah i have not tried that
and i think that the yeah they're
running locally stuff so i've used
local stack to kind of run docker
containers locally for
developing lambdas and dynamodb i think
it
it gets you most of the way there and if
you want to if you really want to run
locally then
those are good options the things that
i've run into is just the discrepancies
because you're trying to basically
recreate aws
on your local machine and so you just
kind of have
discrepancies that you know you might
spend a lot of time debugging
the way this queue is working on your
local machine but
in reality on aws it's it's working just
fine so
um just kind of those things and yeah i
think that the docker support on on
lambda is kind of
a cool thing i haven't used it yet
myself
um yeah i totally agree i would i shy
away
pretty strongly from trying to like end
and test the whole complicated stack
locally but
if you just need to invoke a function
with the first party container support
now
it's really really easy yeah definitely
awesome yeah sorry to butt in
um if if you're curious there there's a
a new project i found that lets you
build cdk and it'll actually
be able to set up a proxy it'll proxy
request from aws
into a local lambda so kind of handles
takes care of that for you it's called
serverless stack posted in the chat
awesome i have heard of serverless stack
and that sounded like uh david
how's it going hey good to see you
um yeah that sounds that sounds like a
really interesting project they've been
doing a lot of cool stuff so i haven't
used it yet
but sounds really cool
awesome um so yeah i'll just talk
for just a two minutes about uh
something i've been working on recently
and then
we can kind of talk about everything uh
keep talking so yeah like all of the
questions
so something i've been working on and
released uh about a month ago was
is called serverless ui so i took what i
learned around building
websites kind of kind of driven from the
website
side of things and built this command
line utility
slash aws cdk construct
around the common aws infrastructure so
this works on aws
uh specifically but um kind of how it
works
is under the hood it's using the cdk
constructs and kind of
scaffolding out like a project kind of
like our infrastructure project here
and it has some custom cdk
constructs to to do the um
those more common things like we were
talking about earlier the
cloudfront s3 lambda api gateway stuff
it does all that for you and so if
you're kind of out of the box
using your serverless application you
have
your functions in a functions folder and
you just want to use the cli then it'll
deploy all that for you
all you have to do is really configure
your
aws credentials locally and then you can
install the cli and deploy and point it
to that directory
so the way that this application that i
kind of went through in the demo today
is working
is kind of the a little bit uh
more advanced version of the same thing
and so we're
we do have a cdk project stood up here
um but it's using that custom construct
and so you see we have a serverless ui
construct that we're importing from the
package
and we kind of define these properties
so we define where
our ui sources folder is and so that's
that build directory that's notepad
creates
and then also where our api files are
and that's
that graphql.ts file which is in our
functions folder
and so um this is still you know
relatively
in its infancy this project but i've
been using it on my
all my side projects recently it's been
working out really well and so
it also has the ability to configure
custom domains and
and uh ssl certs and so
um it's been working good for what i've
been doing so far
and so yeah enough of uh shameless
plugging um
and i kind of want to wrap it up and say
you know
i think that we may be coming to a point
where
you know the generalists are needed to
kind of wire together
all of these different services these
all these third-party services all these
aws services kind of wire them together
be those lego builders and i think that
we may be
coming to a point where we just become
developers again and not full stack
developers front-end developers
back-end developers we're just
developers using all the tools that are
at hand
to build awesome applications so i'm not
sure if that's
what where the future's headed but it
kind of feels that way sometimes so just
wanted to put that out there
but um otherwise i don't have anything
else
it's been great speaking with everyone
and i'm i'm here to stick around for a
while if we want to
chat about whatever
thank you